RETO MEIER: Today I learned that
since 2010, New Yorkers have
been complaining more.
I'm Reto Meier, Google
Developer Advocate.
Join me now as I explore
the trends from the past six
years of New York City
311 calls with BigQuery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Most complaint
types have seen an increase,
but they are not
consistently distributed,
and many categories have
actually seen a decrease.
The most significant
complaint increases
are related to cars,
noises, and garbage.
The most striking are those
related to parked cars.
Frankly, I'm amazed anyone even
tries to park in New York City.
Illegal parking complaints
are up over 400%,
for presenting nearly
100,000 additional calls.
That, by itself,
is almost a third
of the total
increase since 2010.
Blocked driveways
and derelict vehicles
represent another
100,000 extra calls.
So it's clear that
people just don't
know where to leave their cars.
Note that there is also a sharp
increase in broken parking
meter complaints.
So some people, at least, are
trying to do the right thing.
Noise complaints have always
accounted for the most 311
calls.
They have now more than
doubled since 2010,
with over 200,000 additional
calls in 2016, which represents
nearly 18% of all calls.
There's also notable
increase in complaints
about homeless encampments,
dirty sidewalks, and missed
garbage pickups, and a possibly
not unrelated increase in rat
sightings.
Thankfully, the trend hasn't
been entirely one way,
with many complaint types
seeing significant decreases.
The city walls are looking
cleaner, with complaints
about graffiti and
illegal postering
both down, and illegal
postering, specifically,
down nearly 80%.
Broken streetlights and
faulty traffic signals
are both down
around 50%, possibly
related to the gradual
introduction of LEDs,
and street repairs seem to
be failing far less often.
We can also see
that each borough
has evolved in its own way.
Here I'm looking at the
complaint types that
have increased or decreased at
significantly different rates
in one borough,
compared to the other.
In Brooklyn, for example,
derelict vehicle complaints
are more than 60% higher
than the other boroughs.
Manhattan saw the largest
growth in complaints,
and as you can see, really
drove some of the categories
with the biggest
increases, particularly
for noise and illegal parking.
They also went against the trend
for graffiti, street cave-ins,
and faulty pedestrian
signals, getting worse
where the other boroughs
all saw an improvement.
In the Bronx, complaints
about loud music,
on the street and
coming from cars,
have grown at around twice the
rate of the other boroughs.
Meanwhile, in Queens, complaints
about poor street conditions,
including potholes and
cracked roads, are up 10%,
against a 5% downward
trend everywhere else.
Finally, in Staten Island,
the alleys are even dirtier
and broken street lights
are up against the trend.
Remember that in
every case here,
we're measuring the change
in the number of complaints.
You'd expect an
increase in complaints
to correlate with more
problems, but it's possible
that people are just
complaining more.
I've cherry-picked
what I thought
were the most
interesting trends,
but they are by no
means comprehensive.
As always, your first terabyte
of processing each month
is free, so I invite you
to open up BigQuery and do
your own trend
investigations on this
and all the other
public data sets.
And share results with
us using the Today I
Learned with BigQuery hashtag.
And as always,
subscribe to our channel
and follow our blog
to learn something
new every week with BigQuery.